guy roux est ce que vous pouvez venir
nous rejoindre avant la dernière image
de camille combal guy roux vous mettez
souvent des bonnes et enfin sur le
terrain
je propose que jean luc lemoine 20 mais
aussi parce qu'ils étaient abonnés avant
de voir la dernière image de camille
combal
j'aimerais tout ce qu'on refasse un
retour de mon bonnet on va lancer cette
dernière image avec cabine juste après
allez-y guy est ce que vous pouvez me
mettre celui-là jean-luc j'aimerais que
vous mettiez non jean-luc voilà jean luc
je les lance aujourd'hui la météo de
camille combal camille combal salah et
m'a dit mettez dans cette attention
appelez nous apprennent au sérieux mais
les gars
c est une petite blague c'est pas la
bande à bono c'est la bande à voler
[Applaudissements]